au coeur de toutes les attentions les
pandas du zoo de beauval et plus
particulièrement croire roanne la
femelle gestante âgé de 9 ans depuis
l'annnonce de bébé panda hier la maman
est placé dans une loge intérieur
l'agitation particulièrement courte
seulement quatre semaines est très
fatigante pour l'organisme trois points
et on repose pour sa loge de nuit un peu
comme si elle était dans sa chambre ce
que vous voulez c'est vraiment ça elle
est dans sa chambre elle dort toute la
journée elle dort 20 heures par jour
donc maintenant elle est vraiment au
calme sous la haute surveillance de
toute l'équipe panda et de l'équipe
vétérinaire
donc maintenant on la dérange plus elle
est au calme elle repose la naissance du
petit panda est prévue le 4 ou 5 août
prochain une première en france un
événement national mondiale même sur le
globe
seulement 22e ont des pandas et on
dénombre 2000 pendait dans la nature
pour cette espèce classée en danger
d'extinction
chaque naissance est un miracle la
reproduction des pandas ne peut avoir
lieu que deux jours par an alors
forcément la chine se réjouit maman
françoise delord qui a créé le zooparc
de beauval a appelé hier l'ambassade de
chine
évidemment c'était une grande joie un
moment de joie partagé avec nos amis
chinois
je pense qu'on en parle partout j'avais
moi même un ami qui était à shanghai est
fière et qui me disait que l'on ne
parlait que de notre bébé y compris en
chine
allégorie de l'accord diplomatique entre
les deux pays le nom du bébé sera choisi
par les premières dames chinoises et
françaises
les trois premiers mois de sa vie le
petit panda restera au repos à
l'intérieur visible sur écran géant
passé trois ans à beauval celui-ci
retournera dans les montagnes chinoises
mais pour l'heure le pape à wenzhou
continue de se prélasser confortablement
en attendant l'heureux événement